you are watching the press preview the
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the politics editor for gal them
moya lothian mclean and the times home
affairs editor matt dayton
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the observer quotes the archbishop of
canterbury describing the government's
plans to send some asylum seekers to
rwanda as against the judgment of god
justin welby's words are also the main
story for the sunday telegraph
reporting that some victims of the
rwandan genocide stand to lose their
homes in order to accommodate migrants
sent away from britain the sunday mirror
dubs the home secretary pretty heartless
after she and a number of other
high-profile uk politicians were banned
from russia scotland's sunday national
hears from first minister nicola
sturgeon who says putin is a war
criminal and i will not shy away from
condemning him and his regime
the sunday times reports that the
epilepsy drug sodium evaporate is still
being prescribed to pregnant women
despite findings that it caused birth
defects and disabilities in as many as
20 000 babies
the sunday express is unhappy with
environmental and anti-oil protest
groups who've been blocking roads
recently demanding punish eco mob now
and the star has a story concerning a
former actor on the 1980s sitcom heidi
high
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by moya
lothian maclean and matt dathan welcome
to you both let's start by having a look
at the observer and uh this is the
archbishop of canterbury's uh statements
regarding the rwanda plan as we'll call
it um very very critical moya
yes indeed sir justin welding who is of
course the head of the church of england
has made a drastic intervention using
his easter sunday sermon which as i
think anyone who's familiar with uh the
christian faith will know that this is a
big deal um to criticize the plan of
sending uh asylum seekers
about 4 000 miles away
from the uk to be processed which has
widely condemned by human rights and
ngos and government ministers alike
matt this this is quite quite some
intervention by justin welby isn't it i
mean he's not sitting on the fence at
all here saying it's against the
judgment of
god no absolutely not it's quite
extraordinary actually at the
intervention coming on easter sunday his
easter sunday sermon and i think one of
the papers uh report the number 10 were
very much taken by surprise and i think
um the fact that the home office
statement that you just read out had to
be issued so quickly after the front
pages have dropped um
from a home office that doesn't really
react too quickly um to the breaking
stories uh out of experience it is
reflective of how stunned i think
government officials and government
ministers will be at this incredibly
scathing intervention i mean it says it
goes against britain's
responsibility as a country formed by
christian values very much using
uh religion to attack these plans and i
think it will cause all kinds of uh rows
this week as the as mp's return to
parliament uh this week is it's going to
dominate the headlines again i think yes
and i'll just read that full home office
statement to put it in context it begins
the uk has a proud history of supporting
those in need of protection and our
resettlement programs have provided safe
and legal routes to better futures for
hundreds of thousands of people across
the globe however the world is facing a
global migration crisis on an
unprecedented scale and change is needed
to prevent vile people smugglers putting
people's lives at risk and to fix the
broken global asylum system
rwanda is a fundamentally safe and
secure country with a track record of
supporting asylum seekers under this
agreement they will process claims in
accordance with the u.n refugee
convention national and international
human rights laws but but this is a
point in which many are saying that it
does actually contravene international
laws
uh yes indeed the plans have been deemed
uh illegal there is serious concerns
ranged about how workable they would
even be if found to be legal which many
expect and they're not going to be um
and most of all it says a lot that uh
there's been a concerted
sort of condemnation not just from
people within the government not just
from the home office which was reported
yesterday that there's a potential
mutiny from home office staff priti
patel had to issue a minister
ministerial direction um to overrule
objections which i think is the second
to be um issued from
the minister in charge of the home
office in 30 years um but there's also
now this sort of uh moral
objection from the clergy and this is
not the first time that we've seen uh
justin welby intervene specifically um
to do with the current
government's um
policies we saw him i think condemn
uh the
rule of six and household mixing in
september 2020 and how it was
being implemented by mr johnson um but
i've also seen other clergy condemn the
increasingly hostile environment uh
that's being directed by pretty patella
i was at a southwark chris the southern
cathedral christmas address and the
staff there which was attended by the
mayor of london and the ecclesiastical
um the clergy there also used that to
condemn the sort of increasing hostility
towards um asylum seekers and refugees
so this is not the first time we're
seeing this
and it also seems to be part of a wider
concern on the part of the clergy at the
way that um britain's welcoming welcome
that is being taken away as it were yes
and in the uh sunday telegraph moving on
to that paper uh we hear further detail
of the the upcoming sermon with justin
welby actually saying that the plan is
ungodly and yet we read it in the
article that the first migrants are
expected to leave the uk for rwanda on
chartered flights as soon as next month
yes that's right i think that's very
much an ambition boris johnson very much
wants to appear before next month's
local elections that they are the
government is taking action because they
are getting uh criticized from
the right wing uh at the failure to
combat to combat the growing numbers of
people coming across the channel in in
small boats and i think um
i think the home office however
officials talking to them the last week
are
more realistic uh they're saying because
of the number of legal challenges that
it's unlikely that uh we'll see any kind
of um huge numbers of people going there
um this this year i think there may be a
small number of flights in the next few
weeks in the next few months sorry um
and that will enable the home office and
and number 10 to show
voters to show the public that they are
taking action but i don't think even
rwanda is ready to take uh there's tens
of thousands that uh boris johnson
talked about over the next few years yes
and we move on to this story in in the
mirror which if um
entirely true is shocking orphans of the
rwandan genocide could lose their homes
to make way for refugees um
well the the article says being booted
out of britain that that is shocking if
true moyer
yeah so this is an investigation by the
mirror which found that the hope house
hotel which was featured in the um press
tour that pretty cool went on um as a
potential home for asylum seekers who
would be sent to rwanda under details of
the proposed scheme
currently that hotel was occupied by
about 20 orphans of miranda's civil war
and genocide
who have been living there since they
lost their parents and many of them have
no money they have no family
apparently some face lifelong mental
health battles and it seems
particularly ironic a that it's called a
hotel but also that uh you know
traumatized people who have no hours to
go are again being kicked out of this um
building in order to make for other
traumatized people who have nowhere to
go uh it just simply doesn't make sense
and add on to that the other details of
this plan you know cost about apparently
predicted 20 000 to 30 000 for each
person it will cost britain the taxpayer
each person who is sent to rwanda to be
protest that is how much it will be so
even if you didn't oppose these plans on
a human level which i think everybody
should um the plan for the financial
level just don't make sense for people
who are concerned already about the cost
of immigration because they will be
paying more for these people to be sent
elsewhere
matt your thoughts on that that this uh
scheme actually could end up costing a
lot more than it then it might do to
actually implement infrastructure to
receive refugees in this country
yeah that's right i mean it's costing
around about 1.5 billion pounds the
current asylum system in the uk uh but
um i mean i was on that trip to grow
under and pretty patel and the officials
were
very you know they were very honest and
said that the costs will go up the costs
of um this policy to start with will
will be costly
we've estimated it and we've heard it's
going to be around about 20 to 30 000
pounds per person but the hope is from
their view is that over time um this
will deter people coming across the
channel in small boats and then
therefore the number of people that the
uk is having to uh accommodate uh
scientists accommodate and put through
the system uh and and also remove to
rwanda and other countries will go down
so over time it will um actually reduce
in the numbers i was i was actually out
with that hope uh hostel that um the
mirror um
talks about and i'm quite surprised by
that story because that that uh hostel
was actually um it's a privately owned
hostel at the moment um as a just uses a
normal tourist hostel and actually the
london government haven't actually
signed a deal with the private owners
yet so it's not actually even ready to
take people from the uk despite the fact
that boris johnson and pretty patel
wants the flights to start flying uh
from next month but from what you could
ascertain is rwanda equipped to take
these people into their country when
when they are actually a country still
healing themselves from the genocide and
have very many vulnerable people
themselves that they have to cater for
i actually do think they are ready to
take refugees um they've they've
currently um
they have taken 130 000 in since the
london genocide are from other countries
and they have a they have a proud record
of taking refugees from other countries
however they are certainly not equipped
to take the the volume of um asylum
seekers from the uk that boris johnson
was talking about i mean tens of
thousands is just absolutely not
realistic at all and of course we you
know if you're taking that number of
people you're gonna have to make room
and that will mean that other people are
gonna have to make room for them like
the daily mirror to suggest so
maybe might be able to take uh you know
in the hundreds or low thousands but
definitely not in the tens of thousands
looking at the
revenge attacks from russia this is
following the sinking of the uh black
sea flagship uh the motsva um despite
them
claiming that it was nothing to do with
ukrainian attacks on the ship but moya
take us into this
yes so there have been as expected um
so-called revenge attacks on
key targets in the north um in kiev and
parkev
particularly an attack on a kiev arms
plant which was apparently the site
where one of the missiles which sunk
mascara came from um but it's caused a
bit of alarm because it's reminded um
ukrainians that even though russia
russia has withdrawn from these northern
territories they still are capable of um
long-range attacks um with sea-based
missiles so
basically
noah is safe um
but it's an it's a sad reminder that
russia may not be physically present in
the region anymore but they still can
reach it yes and and frightening that
they're launching attacks uh in areas
where civilians might have thought that
it was it was now
slightly safer um it just goes to show
that that nowhere's safe in ukraine
matt no absolutely not and it's it's
quite depressing to read the um the
mayor of uh vitali klitschko warning
people um who are thinking about
returning to actually stay away uh we
we've we've seen on our tv screens in
the last few days that you know that's
uh the streets would keep returning not
to normal by any means but um at least
uh the citizens returning there and
there was a obviously boris johnson that
even he
visited um was it last weekend was it um
so it was quite depressing to see that
actually it's going to be quite
unpredictable for um citizens in ukraine
about where ukraine are going to hit
let's move to the observer um and as we
trailed partygate uh still talking about
it and the the question now is it going
to hurt the conservatives in the
upcoming elections
well i mean
the predictions thus far um seem to
suggest yes but again predictions often
wrong the telegraph ran reports
yesterday of two polls which predicted
tory losses of 800 seats which sounds a
lot the telegraph was clearly quite um
alarmed at this and said if this happens
in a general election kyocerma could
become prime minister um so the senior
tory mps are still very concerned about
the damage that partygate is doing to
the base and the observer is quoting
caroline knox who will have a letter in
the observer tomorrow where she says
that she hasn't withdrawn her letter of
no confidence in boris johnson and that
she's still getting concerted um emails
from her constituents most of them
long-term tory supporters who are just
absolutely appalled as what's happened
the real question is if more fines are
to come which as
predicted apparently uh there's about
three to six fines on the horizon for
boris johnson um so the question is now
that will he be able to hang on
throughout that or will the
um sort of momentum build to the point
where more letters of no confidence are
submitted if more of the tory based do
uh react equally strongly to these um
consecutive fines yes and that that is
the point matt isn't it the conservative
mps
across the country believe that that
many people have backed the party
previously
if more fines land on the the doorstep
of the prime minister then his position
becomes untenable or certainly with with
those voters they are going to think
think twice
yeah i actually think these fines have
come with a terrible worst time for the
prime minister
a lot of people were questioning the
timing last week weren't they um it's
very convenient it came during the
easter holidays mps are away but
actually if you think about it the local
elections what sort of two weeks away is
probably going to be fined uh again
before then uh and i think the the more
this the party gate is in the news uh in
the route to those polls the more
damaging it will be
uh for the conservatives and and i think
although we're not really seeing the
numbers we saw before of tory mps coming
out and saying they're going to submit
and have no confidence i think the
crunch point will come
after those um may elections uh in a
couple of weeks and if the tories are
severely damaged i think a lot more tory
mps will think about submitting that uh
crucial letter of no confidence yes we
shall see indeed uh matt and moya thank
you so much for taking us through the
papers